Legally Blonde itself is surprisingly
accurate for a first-year law movie my
name is Becky I'm Ramsey hi I'm Rachel
I'm Jana and today we're gonna be
answering your questions about law
school what it's like to be a law
student anything you've got influenced
what did you envision yourself doing
with your law degree I wanted to do
calibrates I have a lot of friends who
are boys and bands and growing up I
watched them sign some really not great
deals and I felt really bad for them and
I was like they made someone on their
side to some extent that's what I'm
doing that is literally my sin exactly
they lived in Austin I toured with the
jazz band but wasn't going to be a
musician at least wanted to wrap them
because they were all signing these
terrible deals and I was like I'm gonna
go ahead and see if I can put a stop to
that I first envisioned myself doing
entertainment mock and being an advocate
for musicians that maybe you know
weren't able to adequately represent
themselves I'm not sure what I'm doing
now I was like thinking like I'm all
Sunni I'm gonna like I really wanted my
first week of orientation I remember one
of our professors being like yeah don't
do that because you have to make money
first in order to get into that world
yeah I think you envision yourself doing
something that maybe you know ya might
shift in just a shell what's your most
embarrassing funniest story about Law
School it's got to be getting cold
called on when you have it right cold
calling is probably one of the terrors
of law school today reigns is gonna
speak on behalf of this case there's a
bad day in constitutional law third year
here in the final stretch you're not
reading
yeah I got called huh called : and it
was bad that did happen to me she was
like what did you think about this case
sorry I'm not even gonna lie did not
read this case she was like okay that's
okay
somebody left their wallet under the
seat in their card can they legally
search for that the police but what do
you think like I just can't think right
now
I'm obviously hungover I had a night she
would not let me go for me it was I had
to write a paper on something and I kept
the stupid title 9 it was employment law
so I talked about Vanderpump rules like
20 day I drink a lot of coffee I've
always drank a lot of coffee before
going to law school as a full-time
student a bartender so I just was like
run on caffeine my whole life I remember
in contracts my first semester my first
year I pulled out my trusty handy-dandy
Law School coffee mug
it holds the whole pot so that lasted me
for the whole day took a sip and my
contracts professor looked over right at
that moment and goes Rebecca is that a
keg that's the class of like 92 people
in your first year everyone turns to
look at me and I was like no just my
coffee is it anything like the movies
and what we see on TV
ie Legally Blonde with Legally Blonde
yeah it's not nearly like as dramatic
like a long tedious process right yeah
the classroom aspects I would say should
be somewhat Legally Blonde
is one of my favorite movies ever it was
always on when I was having the hardest
time in school Legally Blonde itself is
surprisingly accurate for a first-year
law movie it goes through the Socratic
method
it goes through like the kind of the
clicky
is the expectation knowledge how to
logically analyze a case how to have
debates in class I think Legally Blonde
is like the gold standard for legal or
law school I'm sorry I forever
the best movie ever how'd you get into
law school boy to undergrad grades you
get a good LSAT score and you write a
personal statement you take the LSAT
from there you know you apply and you
write your personal statement and then
you wait you have to be able to say like
okay these are the schools within my
scope yeah this is where I know I can
apply right you got to be realized you
got to keep adjusting your expectations
and some people they really psych
themselves out don't let yourself out
hair lies why does it appear as though
certain people get a worse sentencing
than others can you shed some light that
is for a multitude of reasons a specific
sentence is never guaranteed for a crime
it's generally arranged different state
laws have different ranges for the same
crime federal has different laws than
state and there still is some implicit
bias in our legal system that I think a
lot of us are working to try and get out
but it exists it's also an unfortunate
truth that it's like how much is your
lawyer cost nothing she willing to pay
somebody as well having the ability to
pay for
[Music]
it shouldn't be that way in our criminal
justice system but a lot of times it is
I will say though our public defenders
really do a great job with what they
have have you ever been arrested no I am
not been arrested no yes I have I got
pulled over from one license plate light
being out it was like 2:30 in the
morning I had a had something to drink I
passed all those varieties us and then
he searched my car illegally which I now
know thanks to law school he found my
acceptance letter into law school in the
driver's seat during the illegal search
and it was like well you're starting law
school in a month I'm gonna take you in
because you're obviously drunk but I'm
gonna charge you with driving with
defective equipment so it cost me more
to get my car out of impound that for me
to get out of jail how do I prepare for
a consultation with a lawyer that is a
very smart question the more prepared
you are going into that consultation the
more money you'll likely save come with
all of the facts that you have the
background of the situation and any
documentation or evidence that helps
promote your side of the case and
anything that might help promote the
other side that way I can kind of review
everything holistically and at least
make a good game plan don't lie so many
people I go in there and they have like
their own version of the story if you're
deposing a client they keep telling you
a different storage card for Aston to
present something do a lot of research
see if you can get a free consultation
first and foremost yeah the lawyers
probably gonna try and give you some
kind of realistic expectation yeah stick
to your story but be willing to
negotiate yeah do you think your job is
rewarding enough for all the work you
put in I
I'm modified over all yeah I do I put in
long days long hours I work in house and
still somehow managed to work weekends
and at the dog park in the middle of
mosh pit but I have some really great
co-workers who ought to say thank you at
the very least or recognize that they
see the work I'm gonna cry that really
does help so I don't think the work they
do is that significant I'm not saving Y
of the city Jesus home but I do find it
rewarding in my own right I work at an
agency we have clients who work jobs I
definitely looked at their contracts at
times of damage honestly like I know
that the entertainment industry seems
like kind of a joke but there are a lot
of people who work here and who need
legal services and legal help for me
it's a lot of teaching so it's most of
our clients see a contract I just sign
it I'm like well let's go ahead and look
at it first do you think going to law
school wasn't worth it for you yes I can
definitively say that it was the best
decision that I've ever made it's
gratifying yeah answer I'm going to go
with yes for what I do now I'm not an
actual practicing litigator so I don't
actually need to be barred I've also had
a boss who's above me who was not a
lawyer at all they didn't go to law
school
that's called business and legal affairs
I'm gonna say I don't know yet I'm still
class of 2015 so still working in my
career I am in a Bart position I'm a
staff attorney it's a lot of work it's
really rewarding I actually really do
like my job I just today's the day my
student loan debits those days can be
harder than others hopefully were able
to clear
any burning questions and misconceptions
anything that you have about law school
my personal law school experience with a
lot of ups and downs so law school gave
me more confidence and I'm yeah I think
about the bigger picture think what you
want to do with it make sure it's where
your heart really is because it's a lot
of work and a lot of money it's not as
terrible as everyone says it is either
law school
[Music]